[Music]
we're talking to stephen in albuquerque
new mexico coming out of school got his
buddy they want to both be consultants
they're talking about doing it together
and he heard a rumor that that might be
troubling like a bad marriage
uh
so what kind of consulting are you going
to do stephen
we're thinking of partnering with local
high schools and helping students apply
for scholarships
okay
either one of you ever done that
well we both uh uh have a lot of
experience applying for scholarships and
successfully getting them um so we think
we're a good fit for uh for helping
people that are kind of new to that sort
of thing
okay
all right
um
all right
uh
what's the business model how's that
gonna have you guys figured out how
you're gonna charge is it parents is it
school systems paying you what's the
model
so the basic model is gonna be two tiers
we're going to have um one opening tier
where we provide um introductory videos
where
um parents or schools can pay to access
the videos where we provide basic stuff
and then if folks want to move up and
meet with us one-on-one you know we'll
offer that too if you know if they're in
our region okay
all right well let me start with the
premise that i operate on and that is
the only ship that won't sail as a
partnership
so i would urge you to try to figure out
a way to do this as
a joint venture rather than a
partnership because what typically
happens
in all the years i've done business
coaching i find almost
zero
i mean it's not quite but it's almost
zero businesses one decade later are
still partners
the exception is by far the the notable
exception is medical partnerships and
law firms but short of that the the
typical two guys that go start into
doing something and what normally
happens is
one of you works harder than the other
one of you has better ideas than the
other one of you makes more sales than
the other one of you is more personable
or more talented than the other and it
can be you it could be switching places
like one of you is more talented and the
other one works harder and so they you
end up there there's this resentment
thing that builds up and you don't feel
like the other guy's carrying his weight
and uh it runs into all kinds of crap
if you are going to
and so i would try to figure out a way
to say okay
uh i'm going to go over here and do this
set of schools you go over here and do
that set of schools we'll compare notes
we'll help each other uh we'll encourage
each other but that set of schools is
your money this set of schools is my
money and even if we create a video
product together
that we share the cost on
when i sell the videos in my schools i
make money when you sell the videos in
your school you make money and just kind
of keep it very separate like a joint
venture rather than a full-on
partnership
i'm going to challenge you to do that
that's what i want you to do because i
think you're going to make a mess if you
don't but if you ignore that here's
still some guidelines all right
you need to get an attorney believe it
or not i i don't want to tell you to do
that but you need to draw up a detailed
partnership agreement
and it has to address all of the evil
deeds
everything that's bad is going to happen
just about begins with a d
drug use
disinterest
default one of you walks away and wants
to own half of it while the other one
keeps working
that's default right um
disability
death
what happens then you now own
half of a scholarship business with his
mom and dad because that's his heirs
because he's not married what a dadgum
mess
you know and so you got to address every
one of the possible negative d's
disability death divorce
drug use uh uh default disinterest i
just don't want to do this anymore i'm
gonna walk away
and go i'm gonna go get a job we're not
making enough money but i'm still gonna
be pissed at you when you're successful
later yeah um and so all of that kind of
crap and so you gotta deal with every
possible exit scenario
and most of them begin with a d and you
need to do that in writing in a
partnership agreement before you begin
and i probably would not put it in the
form of a general partnership which
leaves you up in all kinds of financial
liability i'd put it in the form of an
llc but it still functions as a
partnership and i'm still going to tell
you to figure out a different way to do
it yeah and i i would i would add too i
think that's absolutely brilliant advice
i would not even think about starting a
business i liked your idea i'm going to
edit it a little bit on the idea of you
take one school system in this county
you take the other let's see if we can
prove this thing before we actually
either one of us thinks about a business
let's prove this model first i like that
approach and then the other thing is i
was i'm curious to know if you've got a
situation where maybe steven's more the
sales guy
more of the you know okay this is the
handbook on how to get scholarships and
maybe the other guy's more video related
and we don't know that but in that
situation instead of a true partnership
maybe one of you is like okay you're the
video product producer i pay you
and they work together but it's not even
a joint venture that's a way to do it as
well and the other option is um
just one of you own it that's right and
they pay the other one hey and the other
one can make a percentage of profits as
their income that's right but they're
not the owner that's right when i sell
is anything with two heads is a monster
i agree
so if one was the video specialist the
idea here is is that he gets paid a
percentage on every course you sell but
it's your company and he's your
production it's like a contractor yeah
there's something that we seek out
stephen that i want you to avoid
because it's a it's a
it's a it's a it's mythology
it's a lie
and the that um
there's comfort
in doing things with other people
and not feeling like the lone ranger
there's comfort in you and your buddy
doing
locking arms and working on stuff
together there's comfort when ken and i
work together on launching ken's book
yeah and then when we add to that an
entire team around us there's a lot more
comfort
to that because it's not you know it's
not good that man be alone
and um so you feel more invincible
more strong more courageous when you
have your
you know your guy next to you and and
you confuse that comfort with the need
to do a partnership it can be an
employee employer
relationship yes absolutely and you can
pay him zero salary
only a percentage of profits and the
part that he brings to the table is x y
and z and you bring a b and c
and one of you probably had more of this
idea of turning this into a business
than the other one did that's right and
just because you both want to win that's
what dave's saying is so beautiful just
because you both want to win does it
mean we have to
both be in it together in the same exact
role i think you're right dave that
comfort can turn into contention pretty
quickly if they don't focus on those ds
almost always almost always yeah